[Music]
hi
i'm priyanka vergaria and thanks for
tuning in to deconstructing chatbots
today's episode is a special one because
i have invited anu shivastov from our
cloud
ml team hey anu how are you i'm doing
great i'm really excited to be here and
share some things about
integrating google chat with dialogflow
well awesome let's dive in
we know that dialogflow is a natural
language understanding platform that
helps us design
and integrate conversational experiences
for mobile web
phone and lots of other things and
google chat is an intelligent messaging
app within g
suite built for teams to make it easy to
have one
or more threaded communications in a
virtual room
right so it also has a third-party
platform
an sdk for bot integrations and that's
what i'm excited to
to be talking to you about today well
cool what are some of the benefits of
bots in google chat
so if i'm a user um i don't really want
to have to
install an app for every task that i
have to do so that's you know installing
apps for mobile or desktop
you can just do some of your workflows
and automations in a chat room
by direct messaging a bot with an at
mention to get started
right so if i wanted to chat with you
normally when i chat right i would just
say
add anu and your name would pop up and
then i would start typing whatever i
want to ask you
um so it seems like that's exactly what
you do with with bots you just type
add the name of the bot and if you don't
remember the name it'll just populate a
list of names and then you can select
from it which is
awesome yeah so to make it easy with
bots
you can kind of treat bots as you would
humans in the chat room and then now you
have this uh
team memory in the chat awesome well
yeah so as a developer how do i get
started in setting up bots in google
chat
so let's take an example today we'll use
a use case that comes from our sales
team
our story actually starts in a sheet
google is a large company and it's hard
to know who the right person is to
contact
our sales accounts are grouped into
clusters and each cluster
has accounts and then within those
accounts
we have account managers and engineers
that specialize in skills like
security and networking so it gets
really complicated
to figure out who the right person is to
ping when you get
a question even within your department
so we have lots of spreadsheets like
this
used by the sales team i have a copy of
one of these sheets from one of the
european teams
i have scrubbed out their names and test
accounts uh these are this is test data
and instead of actual customers listed
we have uh we're using some google
products
but the setup of the sheet is the exact
same currently
say if i'm a sales rep and i have a
question about
who is responsible for this particular
piece of information
i would come to this sheet and look for
my answers right
right so for example let's say i get a
question
like who can advise on security best
practices
for the youtube account first i would
want to find
the engineer in that cluster and then
figure out
who is on security or maybe i actually
need to connect
to someone who knows the account info so
i would connect to the
account manager let's say you know i
need
networking for analytics then i would
check here
well this works fine but if you're on
the go um and you're just looking for
this information you really don't want
to look for a street sheet url
and then and then try and find that
information within it because
that can be too hard right and it would
be great if i could just get this
information
in chat most likely what i'm going to do
next
is open a chat tab to talk to whoever i
find in the sheet
and that's where this bot comes in i
don't want to have to
open a new tab and wait for it to load
reducing contact
switching is a key point in using bots
right
and then slow chrome tabs when i have a
thousand of them open
right that would be cool but this sheet
looks pretty complicated how
are we going to be able to extract all
this information
um into things that we need i'm glad you
asked
so we'll actually be using the sheets
api and you're right
this is pretty complicated it's designed
for human consumption it's
you know it's not really a database but
we can work around that
so to answer a query we need to know
three pieces of information number one
the account name
so we can get the cluster number two the
specialty
and last but not least the role type oh
i see that this is going right in
in usually when you create uh bots or
chat applications
you need the pieces of information that
act as your input so in this case these
three pieces of information become your
input to the bot
exactly so i could write a basic bot
that expects these three
inputs in a certain order but it would
be unnatural
and difficult to use as a user i'd have
to remember
the exact order and i'd always have to
spell everything right which i
definitely
don't do and we know that with
technology if it's too hard to use
people aren't going to use it so this is
where dialogflow comes in
yep and that is what dialogflow is great
at doing because it's powered with
natural language understanding and
it helps understand uh normal human
words and
it's okay to make mistakes it's okay to
ask
um you know not in order sometimes and
it would still be able to understand
what you're saying
yes so i'm going to show this to you in
reverse
let's take a look at the bot and then
we'll break it down
on how we built it so let's do a couple
test queries
say i want to know who is on gmail for
data management
great and now we see the follow-up
intent because you need one more piece
of information awesome
so now let's actually break it down
first we need to define the entities
then we'll make the intents and then
we'll implement fulfillment to make this
all work
well if you've watched previous episodes
of this series these concepts should be
familiar but if not
then the playlist is linked below go
check them out
step 1 defining the entities let's look
at the specialties that we have in this
table
which will group together similar words
i
define the synonyms and enable fuzzy
matching to be
generous with the input meaning if i
make a typo which i definitely will
it will still connect to the same entity
the synonyms are really
key to making the system robust right
and say
in this case if you're if you look down
into g suite
uh we can see that they're all grouped
together like
docs in gmail so now let's define the
intent
the intent is a category of what the
user is asking for
their intentions so you always want to
have a welcome intent
and it's best practice to give the user
some instructions on how to interact
with your bot
so when i first add the bot to this room
this is where the response comes from
and then now we want to know what
happens with those intents
or when those intents are triggered so
the actions and the parameters
for those intents right so we've defined
the intent
look up googler so this is where all the
good stuff goes
let's go ahead and put those entities
into this intent
they are all required for this intent to
be fulfilled
if the user forgets one of them i define
a prompt
to get it from the user as we saw
earlier
so if they forget a piece of information
they'll see this prompting question
got it so they forget in in our example
use case right they forgot the account
so
um they see the question to it to input
the account information
yep cool okay so what if they're like
different people
talk differently so they will ask the
question in a different way
how do i train the bot so that all these
examples are incorporated
so that's where step four comes in
training phrases
in my opinion this is the fun part
dialogflow uses a pre-trained model
but we can add our own specific
questions for the spot
so i've added these as training data and
you can see
that it'll detect the parameters i just
told it about
so once we put all that information into
the training phrases how do we actually
know that it's all working how can we
test this
so in the console you can actually test
it out um
exactly how it would work on google
assistant so i know that we're building
ours for g
suite but i will touch on how you can
support multiple platforms just right
out of the box in a bit
now let's see how this actually connects
to the back end in this case the
sheet the sheets api right so um
we would have to go and create a web
hook how do we do that
great yeah let me just go ahead and show
you step five the fulfillment code
so we can look at this node.js code
which is
using those libraries we're talking
about so like the sheets api
the chat api all of these in the
the package which has all of these
libraries
now how can we add the images and
buttons and other types of widgets if
they are needed
for the interaction to work yeah this is
how we make it really rich
we just construct these with json how we
want the chat cards to look and then
push it to the dialogflow agent
we want to make this work with google
chat so how do we make that integration
so here in the integration section chat
is actually enabled by default
but let's say i wanted it to work with
multiple platforms i could just select
some of the other boxes in this section
so it's that simple it was really just a
click of the button to actually enable
it once we got the bot to work
this has been awesome anu thank you so
much for showing how it's done
for anyone who wants to try this out anu
has the code app on github which we have
linked below
and if you'd like to dive deeper or have
any questions
leave us a comment or tweet at us bye
you